[Music]
you did something i'm told pretty cool
yesterday you want to tell us what it is
because it must be very exciting for you
uh yes you're talking about the uh what
else would you be talking about um i got
to go to uh royal spring training wow
the kansas city city royals i know have
you heard easy easy
you're not a not a royals fan i'm
personally louis yeah saying lewis
carter the world champion yeah 85 we
still we have friction over that yeah
that's all right
all right
uh so
so you went so you she went and and you
got to what did you get to do what you
did you take batting practice
it was awesome i you know i i'm a scrub
but i they went they let me suit up and
i got to uh take batting practice with
the team and george brett who is a hall
of famer and one of my idols i grew up
when i was at the cub scouts we used to
go watch him play and it was awesome and
he gave me batting tips actual i'm
taking i'm getting classes lessons from
the king that's amazing and it worked i
was stroking him into the outfield no
really not really i was it was terrible
i was going to say
that's a terrible batting stance
just swat at it were you how are you
doing oh i was just nailing him
killing them
that was just
uh
now i i did you get to pitch as well um
i didn't get to pick oh i did what am i
saying the opening pitch the the first
pitch of the game
what's wrong with you no i didn't just
the opening pitch
yeah that would be i would think that
would be nerve-wracking it's terrible
they you know and they don't let you
warm up you know i kept saying has
anybody got a glove and a ball maybe i
could get a no no nothing they gave me
nothing right so i went out there cold
and naturally uh george brett was nice
enough to catch for me and he gave me
the old you know don't screw it up you
know which is what you want to hear on
the way to the mound sure and uh
so i i worked from the stretch normally
a lot of guys work from the wind up but
i worked from the stretch chair and uh
what can i say i brought the heat
did you bring the high heat i brought
the high heat a little chin music for
who if there was a ghost they would have
got some chin music but yeah what did
you what do you think you clocked with
that with that ball oh i mean
easy 35
walking away 35.